oprah winfrey's exclusive interview with
prince harry and meghan markle drew an
audience of 17.1 million viewers to cbs
sunday evening
that's according to preliminary
overnight ratings data compiled by
nielsen
that number will grow as final ratings
figures are released which will include
viewership across digital platforms
the interview was the most watched
entertainment special since the academy
awards on february 9
2020 and according to cbs the interview
generated 12 billion
impressions across social media but the
interview's ratings delivery fell
far short of broadcast television's
usual high watermark the super bowl
which drew 96.4 million viewers this
year
cbs reportedly beat out rival networks
abc and nbc
and is said to have paid between seven
million and nine million dollars for the
rights to air the interview which was
produced by oprah winfrey's harpo
productions
the rights to license the special
included international markets like the
uk
where it was viewed by an additional
11.3 million viewers monday night
cbs expected a huge audience to tune in
sunday evening and charged advertisers a
premium rate of about 325
thousand dollars for 30 seconds of
airtime during the program
according to ad buyers who spoke with
the wall street journal that's about
twice what advertisers would normally
pay cbs for a 30 second spot at the same
time
you